I want to start by thanking all the many
people who've worked so hard to organize
this event for us we want to extend a
very warm welcome to all of you joining
us here this morning in Cambridge as
some of you know my tenure as president
of MIT has been punctuated by almost
monthly visits to Washington sitting
down with our federal leaders and making
the case for the value and the potential
of investing in science and technology
that is giving advice whether it's asked
for or not for the most part however
I must say I've received a quite
hospitable reception but I must say
occasions like today are a tremendous
relief where we can just relax and
preach to the choir we're here today to
celebrate something very important the
White House Office of Science and
Technology Policy and it's impressive
record of influence and accomplishment
during a quarter century in which
science and technology have become
absolutely integral to the vitality of
our economy and our society as a whole
it's a privilege to have so many past
presidential science advisors joining us
for this morning's symposium but I want
to address for one moment someone who's
no longer with us but who in a very real
sense is responsible for all of us being
here most people believe that the new
administration in Washington is the
second Bush White House but in a very
important sense it's the third because
when Vannevar Bush became the de facto
science advisor to President Franklin
Roosevelt he together with bill golden
who assumed a similar role with
President Truman changed America forever
it is almost impossible to exaggerate
the role that science and technology
have played in America's success since
the end of World War two
in terms of our economy national
security healthcare and general quality
of life and that is in large part
because of an Eva Bush bill golden and
other visionaries who followed him in
that role people like Jim Killian Jerry
Wiesner and all of you who are here
today after the war defense remained the
dominant driver of physical science
technology provided the basic underlying
rationale for the support of advanced
research and education and the benefits
of this success ended up extending far
beyond normal basic national security
considerations but as we all know too
well with the end of the Cold War much
of the broad-based support of Science
and Technology slipped off the radar
screen of national priorities but I
believe we have come to a moment when
America needs a passionate new
commitment to investing in science and
technology and those of us who
understand that need have a special
obligation to make it happen although we
no longer face a single great nuclear
superpower a strong commitment to
broad-based fundamental research is
still vital to our national security
it's vital to our ability to alleviate
suffering and to create opportunity for
people around the world it is vital to
improving the health and safety of our
citizens including the disadvantaged and
the physically challenged but perhaps
above all is absolutely vital to
maintaining and extending the benefits
of America's economic success the truth
is that this country's overall
prosperity in the last half-century is
due in no small measure to what I like
to refer to as America's innovation
system a three-way partnership among
academia industry and government our
universities educate new generations of
scientists engineers and students who in
turn generate the new ideas
industry translates these ideas into new
products and new services and moves them
into the marketplace in federal and
state governments adopt the policies
that make it all possible and indeed
provide the necessary basic financial
support this winning combination has
served our nation well in the
half-century since World War two fully
half of the growth of the US economy has
been due to technological innovation
half and I don't have to tell this
audience that tomorrow's economic
strength will spring almost entirely
from the technologies emerging from our
laboratories today the next few decades
are obviously going to be an exciting
time to be involved in leading-edge
science and technology research and its
translation into the marketplace in the
form of new products processes and
services in fact the promise is so great
but it's easy to take for granted that
our economy will always be run by the
engine of innovation but I'm here to say
that we cannot let America make the
mistake of taking this for granted the
engine of innovation can run only if
government's supply the fuel of basic
support for fundamental research the
plain truth is that as a nation we are
not doing what we must do to ensure our
future strength in innovation in recent
years the number of engineers graduating
from our universities has decreased by
toda by over 20% over half of our
doctoral candidates and mathematics and
physical sciences and our nation's
universities come here from abroad with
an increasing number returning home upon
completion of their studies and there's
another trend that's disturbing though
perhaps easier to correct
federal spending on research and
development as a share of the nation's
gross domestic product is lower than it
was just 15 years ago if America is to
have a bright future we need to lay the
necessary groundwork
today through education and through
policy and research first as we all know
by now we need to improve our K through
12 education system America's technology
driven economy demands that our
educational institutions supply the
innovative thinkers who create new
industries who provide the workers who
will fill evermore demanding jobs that
these new industries generate Singapore
Japan Australia Hungary England Canada
all of these countries leave us in the
dust in the tests of student
achievements in mathematics and science
our high schools must not by default
deny American students the chance to
pursue careers in these ever
increasingly important fields second we
need to attract more of our young
citizens especially minorities and women
into careers in science mathematics and
engineering as a nation we simply cannot
prosper without drawing on the talents
of this large segment of our population
only about 5% of the 24 year olds in
this country have earned degrees in the
natural sciences or engineering 5% by
that measure we now trail countries like
Japan Korea and the United Kingdom just
a decade ago we were leading them by a
mile our colleges and universities must
make scientific and engineering
education more attractive and accessible
to bright young men and women their
workplaces must provide the incentives
and opportunity to make the most of that
talent third we need to make sure that
we are educating our young scientists
and engineers not only in the rigors of
their own fields but also in the broader
skills that it takes to make things
happen in the real world at MIT we're
addressing that challenge through our
technology and policy program or TPP as
we call it founded in 1970
60 PP is now the largest program of its
kind in the world and it fills a
critical gap traditional engineering
education rightly ground students in the
fundamentals of engineering science and
application and hones their technical
skills the TPP tries to make sure that
students also gain an in-depth
understanding of the other disciplines
such as economics law and politics that
ultimately may have just as much impact
on which ideas make it into the
marketplace or onto the floor of
Congress and why as an aside if you're
interested in learning more about TPP
and encourage you to look at the
materials on display adjacent to the
registration tables upstairs well that's
a bit about the educational groundwork
let me turn to the questions of policy
and research I would say that above all
we simply need to invest more in
research across the board now lots of
people don't want to hear this but I
believe it's essential while other
nations are increasing their R&D
commitments US investment in broad-based
fundamental research which takes place
largely in our universities is slowing
certainly industry can and should do
more in this regard at least here at MIT
were working very hard to cultivate new
partnerships with industry in creative
ways in fact over 23% of our research
sponsorship now comes from industry but
there is also a legitimate necessary
ongoing role for federal support of
fundamental science and engineering
research an advanced education period
recently we've all been very very
pleased that the federal government is
making an accelerating commitment to
research in the biomedical sciences but
truthfully it's a bit like giving shoes
to only one of the champion runners in a
relay race
today for every dollar that we invest in
life science research we invest only
about fifty cents in the physical
sciences engineering all the other
related fields combined 30 years ago we
invested roughly equally in the physical
sciences in engineering and in
biomedical research our federal
investments today in my view are
dangerously lopsided now there is a
legitimate question is this truly an
imbalance is it really lopsided or is it
simply a reflection of the fact that
this is the Golden Age of advancement in
the life sciences or as physical science
and engineering are mature and should
slip onto the backburner I believe that
it is indeed a fundamental and corrosive
imbalance in this era of intellectual
interdependence when the most
interesting and important ideas are
emerging at the surprising overlaps and
intersections between previously
unrelated fields that unbalanced
investment represents a serious
strategic error and there may be no one
in the country more better equipped to
understand why than the people in the
room today finally as leaders in this
field
I believe we personally need to battle
the troubling tendency to try to
separate science policy from technology
policy it makes no sense to me this is
an intensely interdisciplinary time his
bio engineering for example science or
is it technology brain research
certainly sounds like a basic scientific
field and is but it would never have
been achieved at its current level of
sophistication without concurrent joint
development of the most advanced kinds
of technologies we must insist on a
coherent sustained strategic national
commitment to science and technology to
and we must realize that we have not one
or two but three partners in this
mission academia government and industry
as people with the expertise and
experience to appreciate these problems
in all of their dimensions I believe
it's our job to work hard to make the
case in Washington for prompt and
continuing action we need to persuade
federal leaders that broad-based
fundamental research is an investment
not a cost that innovation is not
something that will just take care of
itself that our future economy jobs and
security will simply not grow on trees
and that OSTP and the president's
science adviser are not some marginal
academic constituency but rather
represent vital interests of the
American people as a whole this 25th
anniversary of OSTP and its current guys
comes at a propitious time to think
together about American Science and
Technology Policy the people we are
privileged to have gathered here today
have led us from world war ii to the
world wide web looking backward at our
journey we can come to understand what
role science policy has played in
creating as maid in creating the
infrastructure the human capital and the
opportunities that have driven one of
the most remarkable periods of
transformation and change an economic
strength in our history looking at the
present we can see strengths and
weaknesses but above all opportunity
just imagine we have essentially
completed sequencing the human genome we
now know the dictionary of life we have
a breathtaking new understanding of how
humans have evolved and how we fit into
the total plethora of living things
these insights are simply staggering we
suddenly have extensions
our eyes and our hands that allow us to
work at nanoscale in science and in
technology we can create new materials
and devices that are structured one atom
or molecule at a time this will lead to
materials with remarkable new properties
to hugely greater strength to weight
ratios to low power high performance
computing and to medical diagnostic and
treatment strategies difficult to
believe today we have a world that is
increasingly tied together through the
internet and made accessible by the
World Wide Web the information base that
this makes available virtually
everywhere and on his end on an
as-needed basis has begun to totally
transform the way we all live and work
and learn its potential for
democratization and empowerment is truly
unprecedented in human history
information appliances are starting to
turn the corner toward readily serving
our personal and collective purposes
rather than making us slaves to an
endless progression of computers fax
machines pagers cellular telephones
personal digital assistants etc
high-resolution functional magnetic
imaging gene knockout technologies and
our increased understanding of cells and
complex systems have set the stage for
quantum leap in our understanding of the
brain and mind and memory with
potentially huge payoffs in improved
mental health communication and teaching
and learning boundaries are disappearing
boundaries between nations boundaries
between disciplines boundaries between
science and engineering boundaries
between what is fundamental and what is
application in many ways the knowledge
structures and techniques of the life
sciences physical sciences and
information science are simply merging I
hope that our discussions today could be
conducted in the context
this enormous field of opportunity and
change but as we sharpen our focus it
seems to me that moving into the future
with no office of Technology policy to
serve Congress and with few people and
structures in place in the new
administration yet we must think
together about how we in the science and
engineering and policy communities can
serve our nation well as it faces great
challenges both the near term and the
long run
our president and our Congress have many
issues with which to grapple the demands
serious and objective knowledge and
advice based on sound science and
engineering just to note a few energy
and environment including a sound
strategy around global climate change
and sustained economic development new
biomedical research diagnostics and
therapies based on learnings from
stem-cell research development of a new
space transport the stewardship of our
nuclear stockpiles understanding and
deployment of genetically modified
organisms in agriculture and medicine
facing new challenges to our security
bioterrorism cyber terrorism urban
warfare and indeed thinking about the
broad issues associated with the
vulnerability of our increasingly
complex infrastructures launching the
new systems biology that will move us
from the sequenced human genome to a
world of improved health and quality of
life we have our work cut out for us the
bottom line is this it's not what we
already know it's what we don't yet know
that's going to make all the difference
to our future so today as we celebrate
all the progress that OSTP has achieved
over the past 25 years I hope that we
can also come together in another way to
persuade our many friends in Washington
that it comes to funding broad-based
fundamental research now is not the time
to leave the dance floor
it's now my pleasure to introduce dan
Hastings professor of Aeronautics and
Astronautics at MIT and one of the chief
organizers behind today's celebration
dan received his undergraduate degree
from Oxford University but I'm proud to
say that he is also one of our own he
received his PhD from MIT and aero-astro
1980 returned to the department as a
faculty member in 1985 his extensive
published record is concentrated on
issues related to interactions between
spacecraft and their environment space
propulsion space systems engineering and
space policy currently he's focused on
space systems and space policy and
widely recognized for his work on
tethers plasma contractor contactors and
high voltage arcing on solar arrays but
Dan also has a powerful interest and
experience in the broader questions of
policy that concern us today especially
but not exclusively when it comes to
space from 97 to 99 he served as chief
scientist of the US Air Force leading
several influential studies on where the
Air Force should invest in space global
energy projection and options for
Science and Technology workforces in the
21st century currently serves on NASA
Space Science Advisory Council among his
many honors are the Air Force
distinguished civilian award he's a
fellow the American Institute of
Aeronautics and Astronautics and a
member of the International Academy of
astronautics ladies and gentlemen my
colleague Dan Hastings
and it where credit is due the initial
idea for this was not mine but Duncan
Maas who's sitting right there who
actually suggested this to me as some
dinner parties that we were asked in
Washington and so what we put together
this day the day is actually organized
around lunch as the fulcrum in in the
morning we're going to hear about the
discussion of OSTP from the people who
of course who were the integral
participants in it as the leaders of
OSTP and then we'll so focus around
lunch who our president Shapiro will
talk to us and then in the afternoon
we're gonna hear about some of the
issues that are on the plate right now
in terms of things that the current
administration is going to have to face
in the next several years so this is one
take on those issues so so with that let
me actually start by introducing the
first panel which is going to focus on
on some of the pre OSTP years and we
have a three distinguished speakers here
I'm gonna introduce each of them each of
them will have actually no more than 20
minutes to speak and then there'll be
some time for questions there's for
those of you on the panelist students
here who'll be showing you the time so
that we can actually stay on time with
respect to this and then at the end of
the the three talks so there'll be some
more time for questions in general to
the panel and essentially we'll run all
of the panels in like manner so first of
all let me start by introducing William
golden William golden is chairman
emeritus of the American Museum of
Natural History and offers for and
trustee of several scientific and
educational organizations including New
York Academy of Sciences the American
Association of the Advancement of
science Carnegie Institution of
Washington about signing I Medical
Center Hospital Medical School National
Humanities Center the Hebrew free loan
Society Barnard College Black Forest
consortium he's also the director of
several Business Corporations including
a general
American investors company and a block
drug company mr. golden was co-chairman
of the Carnegie Commission on science
technology and government he was special
assistant to President Truman and as
such he designed the first president's
science advisory apparatus in 1950 and
he was presidential advisor and the
initial program for the National Science
Foundation
he's edited and co-authored several
books on science advising to the highest
levels of government including science
advice to the President 1980 science
technology advice to the President
Congress in judiciary 1998 worldwide
science technology advice to the highest
levels of government 1991
next who's gonna speak is that David and
David as president of EE D Inc advises
to industry government and universities
in technology research and innovation
management dr. Davies current
engagements in business include twenty
boards of directors and technical
advisory boards both nationally and
abroad
he's also vice president of Washington
advisory group developing corporate
academic research partnerships
dr. Davis served as science advisor to
the President and direct to the Office
of Science and Technology from 1970 to
1973 from 1977 to 1986 he was president
of Exxon research and engineering
company he spent the first two decades
of his research career at Bell Telephone
labs gladly as the executive director he
also served as US representative to NATO
Science Committee he received his PhD in
electrical engineering from this
institution and then guy stiva dr. David
Stephens broad experience as a scientist
engineer educator administrator he's a
board member of the science service
universities research Association the
Woods Hole Oceanographic Institution
remember the Carnegie Commission on
science technology and government from
1988 to 1993 direct to the National
Science Foundation from 1972 to 1976
during which he also served a science
adviser to presidents Nixon and Ford
he was the science and technology
adviser
Ford and director of the White House
Office of Science and Technology Policy
from 76 to 77 so he was actually the
first director of OSTP before joining
NSF he was professor and department head
here at MIT from 1945 to 1965 and
president of Carnegie Mellon University
from 1965 to 1972 as director of NSF he
strengthened NSF highest priority
mission a supporter of basic research he
says under his tenure NSF's growing
biological and social science activities
was separated from physical and math
sciences independent division a science
advisor he helped convince President
Ford to reestablish the white house
science structure and then was directed
by President Ford to work with vice
president Rockefeller Congress and OMB
to that end the 1976 Science and
Technology Act created the Office of
Science and Technology Policy with the
president's S&T advisor as director and
he was then appointed to that and put in
place there in 1976
Minoo also point out he was also one of
my predecessors as air force chief
scientist I never learned forget that so
with that let me ask mr. golden to come
up and give you a remarks good morning
I'm going to start by quoting Groucho
Marx once remarked as he stepped up to
the podium before I began to speech I
have something important to say
now it's it's not what you what I would
like it to be and what you might think
I'm going to say who the nicest
president science advisor is going to be
because I don't know that either but I
do want to say that we have here the
greatest largest collection of
presidential science advisors in the
history of the President of the United
States in the history of the United
States and I think it's worth mentioning
them you might even be able to get
photographed
there's Allan Bromley does ed David is
done horny does Jay Keyworth is Jack
Gibbons Neil Lane and guy Seaver some of
them was like I stiver were both science
advisor to the president and director of
the National Science Foundation Neil
Lane being another such a one quite
remarkable I think and we were all glad
to be here and I certainly glad to see
all of them alive and prospering the
time is limited I'm going to be just
really touching on things while the
rapidly as to the history since mine
goes back essentially to the Precambrian
and we're concerned with the history of
the future rather than the history of
the past but I'll go over the past
somewhat fragmentary fashion in the
summer of 1950 the Korean War broke out
and things began to stir as to what
should be done about science and
technology by the government the OSRD
the office of scientific research and
development haven't been so important in
the winning of World War two President
Truman was pressed by various people
including congressman McCormick of
Massachusetts who was then a leader of
what was called the big four in the
Congress the speaker I think he was the
house they wanted him to reestablish the
office of scientific research and
development they wanted to do some other
things I got a call at that time when I
was my wife and I would at the Grand
Canyon vacationing and the call was from
the
Bureau the Bureau of the budget that was
in cold
charlisse alpha her assistant director
otherwise known in the Navy that bill
would you come to Washington and help us
by advising President Truman as to what
he should do about the about actions in
relation to the outbreak of the Korean
War I couldn't resist that and a couple
of days later I was in Washington
meeting with Fred Lawton who was in the
director of the Bureau of the budget
Charlie South Karen Delmas thoughts who
were the two assistant directors I
agreed to be advisor to President Truman
on this matter and solid work within a
very few days by interviewing people I
thought were knowledgeable or should be
knowledgeable about the subject and
approached it with an open mind I very
quickly came to the view that it would
not be sensible to reestablish the
office of scientific research and
development at that time that it was
premature and that was not the thing to
do but the thing to do was to have it in
mind possibly to establish later if
developments in the war made that seem
appropriate I did quickly come from
relatively quickly come to the idea that
the President of the United States
should have a science advisor reporting
directly to him and I tried this out on
various people who I interviewed there
were the I interviewed this many members
of the scientific community government
officials former government officials
businesspeople academics in fact
somewhat over 150 people and I really
worked very hard day night and weekends
for - in about 2 and 1/2 months and then
submitted my report to President Truman
on December 30th of 1950 the interviews
are recorded in somewhat
uncharacteristically orderly fashion for
me every night I dictated my memoranda
for the file off to an antique Edison
dictating machine which probably none of
you has ever seen and I had never seen
before in a sense
but it recorded on a wax cylinder which
was then erased in due course by shaving
the cylinder at any rate as I recorded
them each night and here in this book
probably any marker 420 some odd pages
are the interviews which people
subsequently found with some interest
this has never been published as such
but it has been Xerox copies are
available in various libraries including
the Library of Congress the American
Physical Society Columbia University
the Hoover Library the Eisenhower
library and the Truman library I think
I've named them all so if any of you
people are interested in in the in the
written at the time interviews of people
of greater or less prominence they are
available if someone can put on a
transparency the first one of those
would just display these lists the let
me have the other one first another one
first and one that's called alphabetical
list of interviewees there'll be several
pages will just display them I have a
few Xerox copies of these papers which I
can leave here at MIT
that's not washable Alexandre this is to
give you the general idea you like you
know some names and some you won't it's
not there for the papers indicate the
number of times I saw some of them and
then I'll take the table of contents I
think you can show the next page too if
you would
I think that's enough to give you the
general the general concept the I refer
to publications other than my own
memoranda and I think we might show that
list now that's three pages there and
again just to give you the idea and I
will leave on a Xerox copy for anyone
who I may want to look into these over
varied interests some of which I was
editor and co-author such as science
advice to the president which Chuck vest
preferred to previously
wellmaybe of interest there are articles
in these books by every one of the
sciences for presidential science
advisors who was here as well as some
who are and no longer living in fact
every presidential science is why
they're up to date or yesterday's date
is represented by an original article
written by them for me in these volumes
and I've written some relevant papers as
well the only one missing is Oliver
Buckley who was the first science
advisor I'll turn to that I think that's
enough of this way of that you can take
that off distraction the this this is a
science advice to the president which
the second edition contained today as a
material that did not appear in the
first this little book published by the
triple-a s press and not very easy to
get as excerpts from the 420 page book
prepared by a member of the National
Science Foundation staff and he has a
very good article in it himself namely
Bill bland Pete who some of you know is
an old-timer in this
in the National Science Foundation who
is now the National Science Foundation's
representative in Japan bill blimpy does
a splendid job I think about certainly
including in there certain documents
such as a summary but not the full copy
of my report to President Truman in my
report I recommended that the Nationals
that the excuse me that the OSRD not be
revived at that time which was the end
of 1950 but that be kept in mind for
possible activation later on or
something equivalent to it but that the
president appoint a science advisor to
himself will have one appointed and this
was done but quite some time were past
several months while we that being the
budget Bureau of people in the White
House staff and I went through names of
people we thought was qualified who
might be interested I won't go through
the list leader bridge know at that time
with president of Caltech a very
prominent scientist in world war ii and
the OSRD some called him the I later
called him the Eisenhower of of science
was one of the first thoughts and he
declined on the ground that he couldn't
leave shall take another was Mervyn
Kelley who probably won't be remembered
by many of you but who is an outstanding
Bell tell lab scientists and was
outstanding in assisting the military
throughout that whole period of time
Mervyn Kelley was interested and we were
interested in him Bell tell and they
said well you will do even better we'll
give you Oliver Buckley who's Marvin
Kelley's boss that proved to have been
dealt somewhat not from the top of the
deck
Mervyn Kelley was made president of the
Bell tell Labs and Oliver Buckley who
was a very fine man very able and very
active and very important in the OSRD
started off well but he was ill and
deteriorated and he was rather timorous
that scenes went long he was followed by
[Music]
leader bridge on a part-time basis I had
established a job to be a full-time one
we took it on later a part-time basis
and was then followed by hi Robbie at
this point when Robbie was act it was
the science advisor on the part-time
basis I presume you all know why I
Robbie was Nobel laureate in physics at
Columbia University and a very prominent
and important figure in American science
policy and in military science military
related science he he went to our
President Eisenhower promptly when
Sputnik went off in 1957 which is an
arresting event for those who were alive
at the time and told Eisenhower that he
should select a full-time science
advisor and this was done was getting
Jim Killian Jim Killian who you will
know of was extremely helpful to me in
my study and was proved to be a very
practical devoted and in every way
effective science advisor to Eisenhower
I think that covers those aspects that I
wanted to talk about the other things I
was expected to do no I'm not running my
time was to advise President Truman on
some other timely matter than one of
them was the activation of the National
Science Foundation so the Act had been
passed that summer of 1950 November of
that year the members of the war the
National Science Board were chosen
appointed and the question was what
should their policies be and I was asked
to study that and I did and I submitted
a memorandum at some considerable length
which was circulated to the members of
the board in which the basic
recommendation that I made was a
fundamental question that was that the
National Science Foundation should
devote itself exclusively to the support
of basic science and should not get
involved in military science related or
Technology related matters at all this
was quite the debatable issue with the
members of the board and others but they
finally came to agree and accept that
and that was done and had been made was
maintained for a long time as pure
science and the National Science
Foundation I think that well I'd like to
say that in just in the discussions with
these many people I rather quickly got
to us feeling that feeling but
recognized that the idea is there was
president science advisor and the
president Science Advisory Committee
would be acceptable and perhaps
attractive to many of them but this was
there was some debate about this the
arguments about it and after I say
before I know I shouldn't put it that
way I submitted my report to President
Truman and I think it was December 30th
of 1950 after about two and a half
months or so of work the question of
putting it into effect then came up in
the selection of a president science is
right there
this was
somewhat argued in some places but I
felt that I had before submitting the
report the essentially complete
agreement or acceptance of those ideas
afterward it developed that there was
some some lack of enthusiasm among some
of the scientific people and this was
debated and finally did come true to a
knee he lops thought at any rate by the
entire National Science Board I should
say that this was prior to my submitting
the report to President Truman so I felt
that this was accepted and indeed
enthusiastically in some quarters the
selection of the science advisor I've
just described the selection of the
members of the science president science
advisor committee peace act with a
similar procedure and all went well I
should say I'd rather like to say that
in Killian was a very strong supporter
of these ideas and was very helpful I
think in valuably helpful in persuading
some members of the scientific community
that the recommendations were the thing
to for them to approve including the
basic science only for the National
Science Foundation Jim Killian was very
helpful
robert Oppenheimer started very
cautiously and finally came around he
was not opposed at any point but he was
for those of you who knew him he was
cautious in what he would say and he
would express himself what sometimes in
rather poetic terms but he came round to
a a full enthusiastic support Vannevar
Bush another MIT person who was very
helpful to me not only then but in
subsequent years started somewhat
skeptically not opposed but he wondered
whether the president would use a
science advisor and he was supportive
Jim Conant and I call him Jim because
other people did I certainly never did
he was a rather formal man was opposed
to the concept of a single presidential
science advisor he thought there should
be a committee but not a person but he
who became the chairman of the National
Science Board also came around to accept
it so that everyone did accept the idea
it's some very enthusiastically before
they had their first meeting not I'm
sorry not before their first meeting
after they had had their first meeting I
went through this which was in November
of 1950 if I remember correctly the
selection of Allen Waterman to be the
first director of the National Science
Foundation was an other very important
event I think in the history of the
foundation there had been active
consideration in the White House of
appointing because the President did the
appointing of the director of appointing
any man who was a faithful Democrat who
had been defeated when running for the
governor of one of the southern states
and this was I thought a real hazard but
it was overcome and Alan Waterman was
appointed and I think that's proven to
be a very important historic event he
did very well for many years
I'd like to add essentially in
conclusion that the out of the
organization of the apparatus of some
called the white house science
organization namely as president science
advisor and APC has been adopted and
adapted in virtually every developed
country now this is some fifty years
later and every country has something
closely equivalent the the reference was
made by truckwest to the Carnegie
Commission on science technology and
government which Josh Lederberg and I
will coach Hammond the the the work of
that Commission led to quite a number of
publications with some of which I'm sure
some of you are quite familiar and I
think I needn't make no further
reference to it except to say that one
of the one of the developments from that
Commission not a direct part of its work
demonstrating the unpredictability in a
way of evolution with the creation of
something which Alan Bromley named the
Carnegie group this is this var that is
an informal organization which is why
the two formula term for it an
informally organized group that meet has
met semi-annually ever since it was
first convened by invitation of the
Carnegie Commission on science
technology and government about eleven
years ago it consists of the ministers
of science or their equivalents of the
g8 countries and the European Union in
the United States it's the science
advisor to the president they meet
informally with no staff president zero
staff present no formal minutes and have
very informal and open discussions that
Allan Bromley can tell you more more
effectively than I can
this is persisted that no subsidy the
Carnegie Commission invited these
ministers for the first meeting they
liked it they said with carry on and the
they do that moving from country to
country the whole
country is the host the minister's pay
their own freight and they talk very
openly and I hope there'd be some time
here when maybe Allan Bromley can tell
you a little about that in his colorful
smile way I see him smiling over there
so I'm not talking out of turn the next
meeting the next semi annual meeting and
they've literally been six months apart
generally speaking June December next
will be in Canada in the beginning of
June
I wanted to display certain documents I
think I've given you the main idea with
the transparency that have been shown
displayed here so well thank you for
your attention and if there's a question
period I don't know whether it comes
immediately or at the end but when Bush
but I never called him that to his face
he was dr. Bush what would you like to
know about him I would say he had a
rather stiff informal manner sometimes
in a very warm heart a very cool head
and he was very outspoken man you knew
that he was what my mother called
genuine yeah what he said is what he
felt him and and believed marvelous case
for science back then I don't know
whether than this whole background and
his belief in what he wrote but how he
came to do that I don't know that was
essentially before my time
he became the head of the Carney
Institution of Washington as you
probably know and ran that very well at
operating scientific organization with
five science divisions
thank you
filming I mentioned the book that no
language prepared that contains the
selection of the memos that referred to
yes that one do it it's indeed out of
print copies are very serious but the
full text is up on the web in a credible
form as a PDF file on the science policy
section of the term there's the there's
the URL right there
[Applause]
I always have to lower the microphone
and somebody said before I took this job
I was six feet tall looking out into the
audience and seeing distinguished people
many of them I'm reminded of the story
about the victim of the Johnstown Flood
when he arrived in heaven he was asked
to present a seminar on what had
happened at Johnstown and the flood and
when he got up to talk he felt very very
comfortable because after all he'd
observed it all until he noticed it in
the front row Noah was sitting so when I
look out here I see many of my old
friends and even some enemies and it
reminds me of a saying which applied to
the science advisor for that matter
anybody in a high-level in the White
House which is a closed system and one
of the laws of closed systems of course
is conservation and the thing that's
conserved and closed systems like the
White House staff it's its influence
that's conserved and so if you gain
influence somebody else is going to lose
it and that means that your friends in
the White House can come and go but the
enemies accumulate and like entropy your
popularity always declines well I am NOT
going to follow exactly what was asked
for I namely look back at a pre OST or
OSTP period because I really wasn't
there during that time what I'm going to
do is have a look back as far as I can
go and then look forward I was at the
White House as head of OSTP and the
science advisor and from the late 1970s
to
in 1973 I replaced lead a bridge in his
time there he had fought and lost a
number of battles with the White House
staff especially with that fabled pair
of villains Haldeman and Ehrlichman but
he prepared the way for important
happenings he brought on a very fun OSTP
staff whom I found quite inspiring when
I got there in addition to the staff
that he brought on directly there were
DoD State Department agriculture
department and NASA people seconded to
the office and I gather that some of
that activity some of that technique of
getting people from the agencies to work
in the office is still in place and I
think these sorts of people were
absolutely essential to what I'll
describe that was done during the time I
was there the science apparatus really
had a busy time there were many issues
to be confronted and the program was to
be put in place and among the most
pressing were and on many of you will
remember this the fate of the SST
program thank the supersonic transport
there was also a question for the
funding of satellites to establish an
x-ray x-ray astronomy capability the
Hubble Space Telescope was authorized
during that time the post Apollo program
was formulated and the continuation of
the moon flights occurred during that
period as many of you may remember there
were 19 such flights that were scheduled
but only 17 went off two had to were
cancelled that actually had been
cancelled just before I got there there
was the can't secure initiative as it
was called in those days there was the
ABM system
activity which was debated at length and
finally the ABM Treaty which still
exists and still effective
there was the nuclear breeder reactor
and the nuclear nuclear energy generally
and the coal question of how to set up
the nuclear fuel cycle there was the
question of how much funding could be
managed for the so far so called
civilian research that is research
beyond the the government programs at
NASA and the Department of Defense
there was the effort to make the R&D
funding overall in the federal budget
grow especially what was called in what
was called basic research at that time
and it still is called that in many
quarters although I prefer the term
fundamental research that's a quirk of
mine hang up I've got now it's
interesting with the current 30-year
perspective looking back to ask about
the outcomes of all this activity note
that federal funding and this has
already been referred to here for R&D in
the 1960s was over 64 over 60 percent of
the total u.s. funding for R&D in total
today at least in 1999 it's only 28% and
declining still so with that background
what has been the success rate of the
federal portion of Rd leading up to that
as judged by the programs that I've just
mentioned to you that were established
during my tenure there at the White
House of course that is that the
question the answer to that about
success of these program hinges on the
criterion for success perhaps the best
is just to ask which ones of these
programs met their objectives as stated
in the beginning in my judgment the
clear successes in those programs that I
mentioned where the efforts in
krei astronomy the Hubble Space
Telescope in spite of the fact that it
was nearsighted when it was put out
there the final Apollo missions which
were very successful but which I had to
write to the president directly to get
the final mission off the ground that
was Apollo 17 was a nighttime launch the
only one at Cape Canaveral at that time
Cape Kennedy now the ABM Treaty was a
success in some aspects of the civilian
R&D programs that were established at
the time the rest of the programs that I
mentioned went downhill
especially the SST program the post
Apollo program which we still are air to
the breeder and nuclear energy the
effort for overall expansion of federal
R&D is still not in place and this I
think if you look back carefully is
about a 50% success rate now a more
detailed evaluation of the total of
things total programs that were worked
on in that period might result in an
even lower number but I suspect at OSTP
is effort and White House initiatives
overall cannot be expected to be wildly
successful yet past successes have been
valuable just as in the private sector
its successes have been quite valuable
well the land state landscape has
certainly changed dramatically since the
1970s the dominance of military
technology is challenged in in scope and
size by Health Research University
expansion into commercial R&D and that's
something that I find startling new
space ventures energy in the environment
initiatives and expanded efforts to
overcome shortages of qualified people
and buttressed math research
particularly very clearly there's much
to be done and you and your OST has a
job to do in each of these area
but they're going to have to share the
leadership and those activities with a
wider federal effort and with the
private dominant with private dominance
and funding if we look forward to the
future for federal R&D and so far OSTP
there's some similarity of the
similarities to the past though clearly
the driving forces behind federal rit
have changed the OSTP OSTP is supported
by at the present time by a federal
contract Research Center the Science and
Technology Policy Institute S and TPI
this organization during the recent
transition planning operation singled
out 10 high priority issues for
attention by OSTP for the future let me
run through these very briefly I'm not
going to go into any detail but I think
you'll recognize most of them very
briefly three of these concerned more or
less immediate safety and security
challenges to the u.s. three others pose
long-term challenges and are probably
lasting issues to be considered while
four others seem to require greater
government leadership including better
balance across the federal Rd
enterprises which has already been
mentioned this morning by Chuck vest
first let me tell you what the immediate
more or less issues are as seen by us in
TPI there's air traffic control and
safety this problem the problems there
have been around for a long time but
they are becoming critical as air
traffic increases and the capacity of
the system is constrained and remains
about the same
there's export controls many laws and
regulations are outdated perhaps the
only own perhaps only highly classified
technologies should require export
licenses but that's something to be
decided there's the national missile
defense this is a reprise of the earlier
ABM conference
next are the lasting longer range issues
global climate change you're all
familiar with it energy both supply and
demand the u.s. is vulnerable to
California type shortages of electricity
and foreign oil supplies and
manipulations increase costs to the
economy and consumers are really quite
threatening k-12 education education Rd
needs to be pursued on a long term
timeframe there's very little actual R&D
on education that goes on today
education research might benefit indeed
from the structure that we've built in
the in the health research model there
is no in spite of the fact that there's
a National Institute of Education it
does not in any way match the National
Institutes of Health and the structure
that we put put together in the health
area could serve as a model for the
education research there's greater
government leadership that's a that's
the final category first there is
critical infrastructure protection
these include information the
information networks and other assets
controlled by the private sector
so this there's some effort to match it
has to be some effort to reach from the
public sector sector to the private
sector protection from cyber terrorism
is one very major issue there next
there's genomics there are many issues
here for example how to handle stem cell
research and genetic therapies balance
in the federal R&D enterprises already
been mentioned I have the number 95
billion for federal R&D budget last year
and corresponding programs begs for a
more rational approach and a better
management capability of course there
many other issues but none of these I
think are going to be decided or
resolved exclusively by science or
engineering consider eight
alone politics and economics will
intervene just as they have in the past
but science and engineering are vital it
is remarkable that all Administration
since World War two have recognized that
and acted accordingly the rate of
success is not likely to change very
much it's out on a 50 percent I do think
that OS tepees role is changing it
should be the white houses and the
Federals
federal government's window on private
on the private sector and particularly
the private sectors R&D activities and
what the developments are in the
directions of all of that that's an
extremely important piece of knowledge
for federal decision-making in the pub
and public policy now by by proposing
that kind of a of a function I'm not
asking for a purely regulatory activity
on the part of the federal government of
private R&D I'm just asking for an
informational role now that role I think
it's likely to dominate a great deal of
OSTP activity in the years ahead in
spite of the pressing need for work on
the issues that I mentioned in the ones
I didn't mention many of the issues
identified by sntp I will require
efforts which across organizational
lines and that too has been mentioned
here today such efforts have
traditionally been catalyzed by the
white house science apparatus centered
in OSTP and that is still a valuable and
important function overall the
organizational pattern for Science and
Technology in the white house from the
early days is still recognizable if you
look at the organization chart today and
is likely to remain so some changes as
simplifications might be wise but none
of the Clerc current proposals seem
particularly attractive the old idea of
a Department of Science and Technology
are just science
still does not appeal and I think is
unlikely to emerge
at least I hope so despite the 50%
success rate the system we have seems to
work and it is the legacy of the van
Busche era and the modifications that
stem from efforts by succeeding
generations referring to David AB HEIs
publication recently entitled advancing
innovation improving the Science and
Technology structure and policy process
highlights that that that that study
which I've got a copy of here
highlights OSTP and is staffing it says
more is needed but no mention is made of
smtp i which is a on an underused
resource in my opinion more fun more
more funding is needed from 400 the
funding at the moment of Essen TPI goes
through the NSF budget and I think
that's an that's that's a mistake I
think that that funding should go
through the White House should go
through OSTP but we shall see I had one
other interesting piece of information
which I can tell you about and that is
that floyd Kagame has been appointed the
co-chair of PCAST the president's
Science and Technology Committee and he
has been interested in asking what are
the issues that that OSTP and others
should be looking at or put PCAST should
be looking at and I I'm putting together
an answer to this I divided it in two
parts it's I've divided the issues into
a part in which political activities are
going to play an important role in
resolving them among those are ABM the
missile defense thing the energy
strategy global warming and
genetically engineered products and then
there are others where the technical
side is more likely to be dominant and
that is air traffic control balance in
the R&D budget cyberterrorism
and education systems and the k-12 area
particularly well I think if we think
about the future in those terms you can
see a role a continuing role for OSTP
and one that is not incompatible with
what it is done with excellence in the
past and I hope that this conference can
be successful in setting the stage for
that continuation thank you very much
[Applause]
yes III think the first decision is
whether we want to build an ABM system
and whether it's feasible
technologically that still being
questioned and in particular what it
will do to other countries in terms of
their what their reaction is going to be
not in terms of what they say but much
that what they do and so it's too early
to to have an opinion strong opinion
about that I do think that it's it's a
dangerous world out there and getting
more dangerous because of there are
large numbers of countries who have the
will have the capability of delivering
nuclear weapons or even non-nuclear
weapons on this country from a distance
[Laughter]
unintentional the SST program was
started when I guess it was in the
middle 60s something of theirs that was
to build to prototype SS T's that had
performance profiles which were much
better than the Concorde larger payloads
longer ranges etc I wouldn't say more
efficient because efficiency hadn't
really been examined carefully at that
time the problem with the SST was that
many people in the country saw it as
what we call today corporate welfare
there's no reason for the federal
government to get into product
development and they were basically
funding all its nearly as I know of the
was our member of the SST program there
was no matching funds involved or a very
minor amount of matching funds involved
and that hit the Congress was a the thud
in 1969 and 70 and it was argued and
argued and finally Congress voted it
down
it was a shame in some senses it was a
shame because those two prototypes were
within an eyelash of flying and a little
bit of continuation would have at least
allowed testing of those airplanes and
we could have gotten a much about an
entry a much better line on the
pollution that they caused and a much
better line on their capabilities and I
don't think it would have told us much
about the commercial and commercial
applications but it might've even told
us something about that but there were
real problems for example the the sonic
boom the SST would have made it so it
was a big heavy airplane and where they
made a tremendous under sonic boom
and you couldn't have flown it
supersonically over the United States
you would have had to fly only over
water I still think there is some
justification for an SST capability for
flying from the west coast of the United
States to to the Far East furthermore
with very modern technology which was
not available at that time you could you
could have an aircraft which could fly
above the atmosphere so that there would
be no or very little sonic boom but all
of that is nothing but theory I think
that but my friend over here is
referring to is that I think this SST is
dead for a long time to come this also
relates at least indirectly to the SST
decision I wonder if you could comment
on your thoughts on the role of the site
the science advisory committee and
independent science advice and the whole
episode with Garwin essentially going
public with the P casts conclusions
about the SST and infuriating the
president to such a degree and whether
you think members of p sac have a
responsibility to remain silent
on such matters if they've given their
advice confidentially or to come out
publicly or where you come out on that
whole divide there was no agreement by
the members of peace at that time nor
for that matter in recent times not to
go public on information which was
unclassified only the only obligation
was to keep classified information
secret so dick gowing had every right to
go and testify in front of Congress in
any way that he wanted to and I think
that's an important capability because
just as I said in one of my comments
here economics and politics often govern
what's done and if it's technically or
scientifically unsound that should be
made public and I think you can be sure
that the that the
federal government is not so anxious to
publicize that itself in fact wouldn't
so I think that that capability is
something that should be preserved and I
believe it still is preserved by the way
dick Darwin is a close friend of mine so
I have a conflict of interest when I say
that I do not think that dick Garland's
testimony was what sucked the SST or and
he didn't sink the president's Science
Advisory Committee by doing that either
it was a much broader issue than that
okay mr. golden from the president I
think absolutely crucial that the
president's science adviser and the P
sack recognize that they are there to be
advising and assisting the president
they're members of his staff they have
to be loyal to him first they can then
if they disagree their loyalty of course
runs through the United States and they
should resign from their position with
the President and speak out go dick
Carwin admitted he was wrong no he
didn't they got everybody fired
[Laughter]
I did go and a friend of mine - okay go
ahead
first of all let me congratulate MIT for
holding such a colloquium I'm delighted
to be invited to participate in it for
several reasons
it was just 60 years ago next month that
I came by train from California to the
this campus to be in work at the
radiation laboratory MIT radiation
laboratory which was one of Vannevar
Bush's laboratories that was set up by
in OSI Rd and DRC I'm also delighted to
come because I find that the president
of MIT now knows the proper
pronunciation of a neighbor Bush's name
we have been fighting a long time to get
that and probably will for a long time
in the future now when you've heard how
the White House Science office got
started it's a pre it was appreciated at
home we loved it especially those of us
at MIT when Jim Killian was appointed
the president's science advisor and the
first leader of OST in the modern group
and and it performed wonderfully under
Truman Eisenhower Kennedy Johnson and
the first term of Nixon but it had one
fatal flaw its existence depended upon
an executive order from the president
and an executive order can just in one
signature like that it goes out of
existence and that's exactly what had
happened but MIT figured again in its
revival after one year on the job here
my job but the National Science
Foundation by the way that's the best
job in Washington period no question but
a I'd had a wonderful
first year and I came back from vacation
in early January of 73 and I got a call
from a former colleague MIT colleague
George Shultz to come to see him at his
Treasury office he was Secretary of
Treasury and also a special assistant to
the president I went and he said the
rumors you've been hearing that OST will
be transferred the transfer the
functions of OST to the NSF are true and
he said can you have lunch with Roy ash
the head of OMB and me tomorrow and tell
us what you would do when that happens
one day actually there was a Sunday in
between I immediately asked if I could
talk with anybody and he said no can I
talk with with Ray Bisping Hoff another
MIT colleague who was deputy head of NSF
and he allowed that I could do that and
we in fact did meet and do some thinking
I had this choice to make to tell to
tell the president and Shultz and
everybody else that I didn't think was a
good idea and quit or I could and Ray
convinced me to do this he said look if
you quit they'll just get somebody else
that will do it and so why don't you do
it and we decided very quickly well you
think what you would do in two days and
a day and a half to to answer that so I
went to the lunch and I said the first
thing I said to them I think we should
reestablish the president Science
Advisory Committee p-zak and they said
nothing doing with President Nixon is
decided against that and it's going to
stay that way
so I kind of got the impression that
maybe this temporary a relationship
might be a little longer than it could
be and so we set out to see what we
could do
and the only ideas we had was to
recreate the white house organization at
the NSF and in fact we set out to do
that now we tried to get a number of the
OST staff to join us I don't blame them
for feeling that it was a step down from
that glamorous position in the old
executive office building and the
executive staff of the President of the
United States but a Dave Bickler helped
a great deal and in getting one
important appointment for that part of
the organization we set up and that was
rusted route I had the what we call stip
OS tpo Science and Technology Policy
office to handle a great deal of this a
short time thereafter Phil Smith joined
my staff as my executive officer and he
did the important job of making sure
that I didn't neglect my
responsibilities on either side of this
terrible split that I was in and he and
my longtime secretary there are some
Karn
who knew everything about Washington
science made sure that I handle this by
the way I think I'm only missed in three
years one National Science Board meeting
but by the way this decision that the
White House was taken without ever
referring to me as head of NSF or the
National Science Board completely in
fact I was warned not to bring them in
and to our early thinking but I
convinced Shultz to come and talk with
him and some of them I think saw stars
in their eyes that we would go back to
the original prep proposal that NSF
would be the Grand Central operational
law
item in science technology others of
them sought temporarily but we better do
a good job and in fact they immediately
voted to establish an advisory committee
for me in that role that meant I had an
advisory committee from of outsiders the
members of the National Science Board
were outsiders and so we were ready to
take off they they didn't like F CST
that's the Federal Council on science
and technology why because it had too
many subcommittees and you know white
houses are suspicious of a lot too many
organisations running around and I
agreed that we would make an analysis of
that and cut them back if it appeared
necessary so I started that analysis and
sadly enough we got it from 14 down to
12 and they agreed to the rest of them
but the sad thing was that one of EDA
votes very favorites the one on
tunneling technology was one of the two
that got cut and I apologized for the
first time and so we went forth and
there was I say a minor ripple in the
science community when all of this B
went public a minor ripple being
something related to a nuclear blast and
but the best thing about all the
criticism of this new arrangement is
everybody criticized the arrangement but
no one attacked me from the community
and I thought that was just I would must
be a great guy but then I remembered I
had this tremendous power are still
being the director of the NSF with an
awful lot of money to spend on favorite
projects and so that worked out okay
okay and but this occurred by the way it
right at the at Nixon's second
administrator inauguration
this was long before Watergate we hadn't
heard of Watergate by then and so we
started with the president by the way I
think that a good success of a system in
the White House is a to be in the White
House as advisor to a second to be the
with a president who is understands
science and technology and knows he
needs it and third to have a group of
very important problems if you have
those three why we you can do something
I was out of the White House
I wasn't sure really of the president's
understanding of Science and Technology
although I changed my mind on that he
understood it he really liked science
and technology President Nixon but he
didn't like scientists
and but we went on and it was the whole
change his new order of our organization
wasn't to take place until July but the
people at OMB didn't wait they
immediately asked me if I would present
the new budget that was to be presented
that would be the 74 budget presented in
January of 73 and as well as the NSF
budget and I accepted this and Dave
Beckler and and what's-his-name over at
OMB put me through a course of sprouts
so showing me how that budget had been
constructed and so I went forth on that
then what were the problems we were
going to get well
Edie David had started some very
important things one of them was and
this was of great interest to President
Nixon and that was date on with the
Soviet and he had started the science
part of that detailed date on and we
picked that up and we had all the rest
of my time there three years in this
role we had wonderful meetings with the
Soviet and each time they their Deputy
Prime Minister who was there ahead of my
counterpart would have been Ed's
counterpart mm-hmm every time they came
we got them in to see the president and
every time I went over there I got to
say well what first was Pat Gorney and
the second was kosygin's
and they told me well I those meetings
were so important and so I'm not going
to talk about them but they were quite
interesting and what they said
essentially to us in those meetings
those two meetings with the leaders was
that they talked with the United States
is so important to the Soviet
Union that they would not raise any
trouble in the Middle East where we were
having an energy crisis nor would they
interfere with what we were doing in
Vietnam now that was a pretty big
promise and we never were able to live
up to it well by the end of that first
year we are we were well staffed roster
would come in as head of the OST part of
our organization and and we add that
Paul Donovan and Paul Craig from the
rand program on a big Energy Pro thing
because energy was becoming a very big
thing and that also had been foreseen by
the OSTP before and they had some very
good work on it and in fact we are we at
NSF had already been assigned geothermal
it and and solar energy and we built
them up in the ran program quite too
heavily we were also doing Studies on
energy efficiency new analyses of energy
systems and on and on and on and
immediately in the fall came the well
embargo OPEC oil embargo which sent this
country into panic and especially the
government into panic more things were
done in a hurry to try to do something
in a in a hurry like as is being done in
California today and the same issues
came up by the way and first the
governor love came in as the energy czar
and governing me love immediately asked
me to establish an energy research and
development committee to help him this
was from the private sector so we got a
private sector advice and President
Nixon started a program called Project
independence which would be independent
from all imported oil which was hopeless
and then John Sawhill became head of a
Federal Energy administration to conduct
that we
help him we helped when in the energy
program when the ADA was formed and we
helped to get another MIT colleague from
the same Department Bob Siemens is the
first director of do you have sense some
kind of a cabal here well there was one
[Laughter]
and by the end of the 73 we were all set
to handle anything and we'd gotten the
president interested in not only in
Dayton but in reestablishing the
National medals of science which had
dropped off for two years
and so I had the pleasure of two years
of four years of officiating at that
thing that was kind of fun well when in
the end when when Watergate took hold of
the country and shook it up pretty badly
as well as energy and it became clear
that President Nixon wouldn't be able to
say and so this time the National
Academy set up with Jim Killian as a
chairman a committee to explore the
restoration of science back in the White
House they thought with when if
President Ford came in Vice President
Ford came in they had a chance and they
did they talked to President Ford
I talked to President Ford and at that
time when he was vice president he said
two things to me he said I want to
reestablish science in the White House
as soon as we can but I want to do it
with an act of Congress which can't be
signed away by a president that was his
most important thing and the second
thing is I would like to see the fights
budgets improve increased
and why we had shown him science
indicators everybody knows science
indicators a very popular publication of
the status of science and I was there
sitting there at a coffee table with
leafing through all the stuff in this
thing to show him and he suddenly
reached back and he turned the thing
aces what's this and there was a plot of
the the proportion of the the the annual
GNP of the United States which would go
into our DTN a research development
technique and he looked at it and here
was our thing was coming down like this
Germany was going up like this Japan was
going up like that he instantly says and
you know those two countries don't even
have a have a military budget to R&D
budget so he recognized right away and
by the way at the end one of the one of
our proudest accomplishments was in the
last two budgets that Ford presented
both of which first stop the downtown it
started it up and this was well when
Ford got there he said within the first
week and when I met him in a in a
reception line at the White House what
he invited the presidential appointees
there by the way everything done in a
reception line or the cocktail party or
a casual meeting at the dinner
everything important is in Washington is
done that way and he said to me I want
you called me dr. Steve ER and they
right up to the end he never called me
guy until the end but dr. Seaver I want
you to continue the to Hat arrangement
until we can get the the Act passed the
act that we are celebrating today and
well to make a long story short it was
came a long story it was another two
years before I finally I was nominated
to be the first ahead of OSTP and that
meant I had to drop my favorite
employment
which was the NSF that thing that act by
the way we should really we really
should celebrate it was good then and
it's still a good one
and the most important thing is that it
it has to it's there if a president
ignores it for a while the next
president well it's there to face the
next president and so on and there are
lots of people in Congress who will
support getting it going again and I'm
delighted there were some things we did
to help after all we inherited several
big problems areas from from ed ed
david's area and and we benefited from
him and we sent on some things to the
next group well one thing we sent on was
Phil Smith as the who joined Frank press
and made a wonderful team with under
Jimmy Carter President Jimmy Carter and
we so we that was one of our gifts but
we there was one thing we tried in I'm
sorry that Congress tried to get OSTP no
peace a Cree established but the
administration resisted it I was on the
side of Congress but I was in one of
these difficult positions because I was
the fellow that went back and forth
between Congress and the president and
all the negotiations to get that act
pass
I didn't felt like a tennis ball you
know in a difficult rally being battered
back and forth between there but
nevertheless there was a compromise and
there was a one part of that bill which
did create a president Science Advisory
Commission which Commission on science
technology which we set up immediately
and that was to act for two years and
then decide whether it should be a
permanent thing we had set up under Bill
Baker and sy Remo two committees before
that happened when the Act was passed
we immediately took those two committees
combine them I Ramos i Remo chairman and
Bill Baker second-in-command and we put
together I think almost two dozen major
issues and study had committee studying
them and ready to take off and that was
another gift that we gave to the next
one my message is one of continuity
thank you
my message is one of continuity is that
what you've been showing me for in the
last ten minutes
well you've got to put bigger letters
and also flashing letters I'm through in
any case my message is one of continuity
we we owe I was the one that lit the
first candle in the first birthday of
the modern OSTP that's why I'm here
today
and any questions for dr. Steve
and he but this was right at the time
that written the war in Europe badly
[Music]
that committee was set up they set
themselves up and the neighbor Bush
Republican got in very well with with
President Roosevelt you'd you said that
he he was a straight shooter and and
Roosevelt appreciated that and Roosevelt
through everything with respect to
Science and Technology to Bush and he
started NDRC we started the radiation
laboratory it started OSRD which the
office in London to which I went and and
they Beckler was there and this was this
was this was the organization which
recruited academic scientists to work in
wartime labs one of which was here
[Applause]
so thank you for those perspectives so
now having dr. Stephen having grounded
what happened to OSTP in in the Congress
I'm now going going to introduce former
representative John Edward Poulter John
Porter is a partner in Hogan and Hudsons
Washington DC office and a member of the
film's Health Group he concentrates his
practice on health law on education
matters including administrative and
regulatory international legislative
strategy education health policy prior
to joining Hogan and Hudson mr. Porter
served 21 years as congressman from
Illinois stent district in Congress he
served on the Appropriations Committee
is chairman of the Subcommittee on labor
Health and Human Services education vice
chairman of Subcommittee on foreign
operations vice chairman of Subcommittee
on military construction he's received
more than 275 awards for his service in
Congress including many awards for
leadership on behalf of biomedical
research for a support of science
research and for his work advancing the
cause of human rights so with that a
congressional perspective I appreciate
being allowed to participate in the
celebration and critique of the
relationship of Science and Technology
to government although everyone here has
been a part of that relationship I
believe that I am the only non scientist
on the program and in a unique position
to see science and technology from that
perspective as a member of the
legislative branch but first let me
express to dr. vest and the MIT family
what a special pleasure it is to be back
on campus for the first time in 47 years
I was a student here in 1953-54 and it
was here that I gained an appreciation
for science and some understanding of
the scientific method he was here also
that I
I'm a Chicagoan froze during that cold
and extremely snowy winter I can
remember the dormitory one large room at
the top of our fraternity house in
Boston where everyone slept in bunk beds
about 40 in all with all the windows
wide open all winter long a health
regulation each of us slept in the sweat
suit and every bunk had multiple
blankets with an electric blanket at the
bottom tangles of wires ran across the
floor to vastly overloaded circuits
violating every fire-department
regulation those nearest the open
windows would often awake with three or
four inches of snow on the foot of their
bunks it was a wonder that we all
survived in any case I returned as a
non-scientist
but as one inspired by the achievements
and possibility of science possibilities
of Science and Technology and as a
committed science advocate to the
federal government as an appropriator
for 20 years it was my privilege to rub
shoulders with the leaders of the
National Institutes of Health the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention the health resources and
Services Administration and the Public
Health Service and the agency for
Healthcare Research and quality and to
be involved not only in funding those
agencies but often in issues affecting
health and science in the Congress to
place our celebration in perspective and
to reach a bottom line Science and
Technology have impacted Congress and
gained support based in the Maine on
their perceived utility to societal
goals OSTP has variously been more
important or less within the executive
branch and with Congress depending on
the president's priorities and the met
and the demands and issues of the day
in other words respecting both Congress
and the executive branch there is for
science and technology
still a long way to go others can
comment far better than I as to how
science and technology and OSTP have
fared in any specific White House my
perspective is that science and
technology have yet to be perceived as
important goals for the nation and that
they have been called to the table as
needed as as the need has been perceived
to do so and that few presidents have
come to office with scientific
background or understanding only
Jefferson and Hoover come immediately to
mind the same problems exist in the
executive branch you will find science
and technology portfolios in at least
nine departments and four major agencies
of the federal government we can
celebrate this as an ascent of Science
in its importance within our government
and to the American people but because
appropriation structures in Congress
mirror this departmental setup the
Congress has spread science funding
through a number of appropriation
subcommittees and in all but one the one
I was privileged to chair it is a
relatively minor part of the
subcommittee's allocated funds and
unfortunately gets an eloquent measure
of the members attention suggestions
have been made for the last 100 years
and most recently twenty-five and five
years ago for concentration by creating
a federal department of science but
always these have been rejected and
undoubtedly they will continue to be the
problem of lack of scientific training
and background or even understanding
among members of Congress is profound we
have two physicists one chemist and
eight MDS together with five engineers
and four dentists all of them but one
list and other occupation in the House
of Representatives that is probably a
high-water mark but it's really about 11
to 15 out of 435 members or maybe 2 to
3% of the House of Representatives amid
a slew of attorneys in the 100 members
we have one heart transplant surgeon and
two veterinarians and I might add a
professional baseball player an actor
and a jewelry designer the chairs of the
Senate and House subcommittees funding
the largest science portfolios are
lawyers or business executives the
chairs of the respective authorizing
committees the one who writes Science
and Technology Policy include a
first-term lawyer a naval officer a
county official and a farmer this is to
say nothing about their appreciation and
commitment to science and technology
but only to reflect on their all too
typical backgrounds in the legislative
branch although we have filled in with a
knowledgeable staff this reflection of a
lack of scientific education or
understanding in the legislative branch
probably for ordains the approaches of
members of Congress to science and
technology matters they are first of all
often preoccupied with other issues they
are they are likely appreciative of
science but uncomfortable with their
lack of knowledge and understanding they
would be likely they would be unlikely
to have ever heard of the Office of
Science and Technology or to know the
initials OSTP they would probably
recognize that the president has a
science advisor but few would be able to
recognize him or her when science and
technology technology matters arise they
largely depend upon staff giving science
advocates a strong hint of staff
importance in shaping policy and funding
lacking an understanding of scientific
method and the off time serendipitous
nature of research as well as any
distinction between basic and applied
science they believe generally that
research must justify itself itself
insert in terms of serving specific
societal goals and can simply be
directed and funded to achieve them
consequently they have been earmarking
too much research for the past 120 years
or so to the point for example that
today 50% of the research funding in
Agriculture's budget is specifically
earmarked on the other hand we have
fought disease of the weak mentality in
Congress for the past 50 years and
mostly succeeded but patient advocacy
groups have become better funded more
sophisticated and more militant the
demands on members to push one disease
ahead of others for research funding
increases year by year education of
members that research priority should
always be scientifically not politically
determined even recognizing that there
is politics within science is
increasingly needed this does not mean
that members shouldn't have or don't
have strong opinions or Express them
merely that they should stop at the edge
of the water and forbear mandating those
opinions upon the research community a
consequence of all this the best
argument for Science and Technology
funding in Congress is its positive
effect upon the American economy it's
the economy stupid the most profound
political statement made in the past
century is something members of Congress
can understand high-paying high tech
jobs are very persuasive as a commodity
Science and Technology with a military
aspect has always been an easier sell
Jefferson had no trouble getting
Congress to fund Lewis and Clark when he
made it a military expedition and put
military officers in charge science that
holds the promise of saving lengthening
lives to be fair also stands a chance
witness the Congressional commitment to
doubling funding for medical research
through the National Institutes of
Health
yet in Congress you may run into not
only the nativist anti science populism
that has from time to time raised its
ugly head but also the clash of science
and religion well recorded in our
national history in this regard the
stem-cell research issue is most current
basic science is harder but I still
revel in the primetime television
program in 1995 where Sam Donaldson
refuted an attack on science projects by
the citizens group perhaps you remember
that program despite all this our
country has become and remains the world
leader in science and technology and
fortunately the synergy and partnership
between government funded research and
industry Rd largely drives our economy
re cut our economic destiny I believe
lies in education and research in
education and technology yet in America
science careers are not hot most of our
children seem to we want to be
stockbrokers these days in science
education and many of our schools is not
a high priority and qualified science
teachers are hard to find if we had not
had the influx of foreign science talent
and brainpower
I believe would be we would be in
serious difficulty thank God for our
emphasis on human freedom and open
scientific inquiry today we have a new
administration in Washington it follows
one which professed a high degree of
value in science and technology but as
in so many other areas in my judgment
fell short in leadership and commitment
in the new administration any new
administration the science advisors
should advise on the selection of key
science people in other federal
departments and agencies
unfortunately no science advisor has
just been appointed in this new
administration
budget impact is also needed from a
science advisor to the president one new
presidential budget for fiscal year 2002
has already gone forward without science
advice and with a real decrease for many
science accounts and another is
currently being put together so science
advice may miss the next budget cycle as
well I might add editorially and perhaps
all of my comments this morning our
editorial that a number of science
issues already have been dealt with
without the input of a presidential
science advisor from Kyoto to our snick
and drinking water to co2 emissions to a
national ballistic missile defense
system so while science and technology
are ascendant in America they are not so
ascendant within the Congress or in the
White House
indeed OSTP s own appropriation over the
years has languished funded at 2.3
million dollars in 1977 it is only 5.2
million dollars for this fiscal year
even though aided by many fellowships
from other departments and agencies the
overall budget is less in real terms
today than it was 25 years ago and the
new administration is targeted it for a
1.3 percent increase which is a real
decrease for fiscal year 2002 all this
leads to me to my conclusion if Congress
and at times the executive branch if
government will not come easily to
science science must come to government
there was a great need for scientists to
take a more active role in civic society
in our country not too long ago the
science community was described as a
weak disorganized
parochial political constituency but
this is changing led by broad-based
groups like research America and by the
way that's an imperative research
America there has been real progress of
late in science advocacy
yeah well we have largely succeeded in
doubling funding for medical research
support for the physical sciences has
lagged behind federal support for
chemistry for physics for mathematics
for engineering the physical sciences
should also be doubled and with a
concerted effort this can be
accomplished nothing sticks in the craw
of this utilitarian former congressman
than that with research clearly
establishing obesity as a serious health
risk for heart disease cancer and
diabetes the American people
particularly our children are getting
seriously more obese isn't that strange
we must translate knowledge gained
through research into behavior and
practice and we can with a concerted
effort double the funding for the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention and for the agency for
Healthcare Research and quality as well
what all this takes are more involved
members of the scientific community the
world is increasingly technical those of
us who are not technically trained most
of us need guidance Marci Greenwood the
Associate Director for science in the
OSTP during the last administration
recently spoke on developing citizen
scientists and I commend her remarks to
you among many important points dr.
Greenwood emphasizes that if members of
the public understand more about science
they will be more inclined to spend
public resources on research while I
realize that scientists by nature often
feel uncomfortable with advocacy if we
all stayed within our comfort zones very
little would be accomplished though
perhaps they are not well understood
scientists are highly respected in our
society they are also highly credible
when they speak with a unified voice
people listen while recent progress has
been made this power he has yet to be
fully developed or applied some way
should be devised
to work it into the academic training of
future scientists the political door can
be opened by scientific advocacy but
like everything else this depends on
leadership now is the time for all good
scientists to come to the aid of their
country thank you for listening to me we
can take one or two questions for okay
in the absence of any
first let me apologize for my voice I
have allergies at this time of year and
they they plague me I would go back to
1995 when the Republicans very
surprisingly took control of the House
of Representatives and Newt Gingrich was
elected Speaker immediately because
Republicans wanted to come to grips with
the budget deficits that were huge and
plaguing our country in our economy
commitments were made to cut federal
spending in almost every area and the
budget resolution that passed in the
spring of 1995 cut funding for the
National Institutes of Health by 5% per
year for five years what our 25 percent
overall cut I was the new chairman
having served on the committee for 15
years was the new chairman of the
Appropriations Subcommittee that funded
the National Institutes of Health
I thought the budget resolution was very
frankly insanity I talked to some people
in the scientific community who gathered
together a group of researchers and and
CEOs of major pharmaceutical and biotech
companies and made an appointment to see
the Speaker of the House I think there
was nine of us or 10 of us around the
table and the speaker gave us his
attention for about an hour and they
laid out for him why in very forceful
terms why this was policy that would be
a disaster for our country lose our
leads in in biomedical research and
setback the possibilities of
breakthroughs in this area by not only
the five years but for a long long time
to come all the momentum would be lost
young people would not be able to see
this as a career
and at the end of that time the speaker
said to his credit I think we made a
terrible mistake
and I'm going to do everything I can to
reverse that and to his word he has
become a very strong advocate for
medical science research and even
remains that today what came out of that
was my subcommittee was ordered to cut 9
billion dollars in discretionary
spending from a seventy billion dollar
budget down to 61 billion dollars and
while I had to do that I I took CDC and
NIH and went to the speaker and said I
want to give NIH a five point seven
percent increase and I want to give CDC
a small increase and I want to take them
out of this budgetary war and pass them
the separate bill which is unprecedented
and and send it to the president for
signature so that they will not be
affected by cuts that have to come in my
subcommittee and the speaker said he
would support that he said you're going
to have to clear it with the Senate go
over and see Bob Dole I went over and
saw Bob Dole Bob Dole knows the
importance of medical research and was
treated in my hometown of Evanston for
very very serious injuries after World
War two and he said I think that's a
wise thing to do we put them in a
separate bill put them on the floor and
pass them out and we got them out of the
budgetary wars and that that set the
stage for a focus on medical research
that we were able to sustain by
increases of about seven percent in the
next two years and then our economy
having turned around we began to pull
the people together that would support a
doubling of funding for a biomedical
research over the over the next five
years we have now completed three of
those years the president in his State
of the Union address committed to a 2.8
billion dollar increase for NIH for the
next fiscal year that is about 13 and a
half percent not quite where we want it
but we're working on that but the
difficulty has been and this is what I
want to emphasize the difficulty is that
you shouldn't have the life sciences
going forward and the physical sciences
not
going forward with them and and the
difficulty in Congress is that I had
control over NIH and CDC but I had no
control over NSF or NOAA or NASA or
defense or energy or all the other
places in the federal budget where there
is basic research funding and so it is
it is I think very important now to take
this base that we've built for medical
research and one of the lead
organizations and I've just joined the
board of it of research America take
this space and research America's
already going to Congress and saying
you've got to fund the physical sciences
as well and work work this into a next
step of doubling the funding for the
physical sciences and research all
across the government and I think as I
said a moment ago that we can do this
with a concerted effort it can be
accomplished - we set our minds to it
I'm sorry I just want to say we brought
you a visual mr. Porter it makes the
same point you were just making okay
[Applause]